two months removed from being the guy
who says yes let me on bail giving you
that money and we were all talking about
how it was a good contract for the Jets
the time based on you know what Le'Veon
Bell is expecting or what he was holding
out for you know
yes CJ Mosley will pay you all that you
know no we're not gonna get Matt Paradis
to be the center after all that they
bounced him now the interim general
manager is Adam GaSe and I figured with
me in a vulnerable state who best to get
the information from and not only one of
the the goats but also a great friend
who knows who knows just how fragile I
am with this information
he's Adam Schefter of the worldwide
leader how are you hello they changed it
well how am i doing well I mean and
again you want to go back 48 hours
beeline going to the state of Ohio that
that one left the mark to by the way
that working out so far for him well I
mean I thought for a split second he
might get he might wind up with Zion but
Brockman knows how much I love beeline
they might get Durant because of how
great Moe vogner looked in that beeline
offense for all those years Adam I'm
curious about this in all honesty why
well I I have an idea I think last year
he was really tempted by the Detroit
Pistons right yeah and I think that he
felt like he was told that the team
wasn't gonna be very good the team wound
up making the playoffs and I think there
was a part of him that was longing for
that job and I found out at the and it
so dress oddly enough rich dead John was
in play coach Elon was in play for that
Cavaliers job and it went under coming
down when it did but I wonder now
knowing what I did why he just didn't
wait till after the lottery so he can
make a full and complete decision but I
think honestly it ties back to a certain
extent to last year and the fact that he
consider and I think he lamented that he
didn't take that Detroit Pistons job no
sir
what are you hearing about b-line
successor I mean could you is it Juwan
Howard you think Adam I mean what are
you hearing if you're hearing anything
I honestly have not heard anything on
that right now rich I don't know the
answer I think that JaJuan how would
make a good choice but again you look at
the way players have returned to the
alma mater it has really fared very well
for like Clyde Drexler or Ewing some you
know he did a decent job for a little
bit there's another one I forget Mullin
that didn't work out it st. John at all
that's it yeah so the history of heroes
going back to the universities to leave
those programs is not exactly a great
one now do you want out it may be a
different case I don't know right okay
but that I think that gives you pause to
investigate at least like if I were if I
were mission and they asked me I did an
email to volunteer my help but though
nobody's gotten back to me no um I would
say I would make a call to Billy Donovan
see if he would want to come back to the
college ranks that's be tempted at all
let's go coach to college again I think
that would be a great way about doing
this rest part of the rumor mill all
right I know I only have enough for a
limited amount of time there and this is
the time of year we're gonna be up by
midnight we're good ok fantastic I love
that all right am i losing another draft
analyst and come on now really you tell
me you tell me I think it's definitely
possible ok I'm not telling you that it
will happen but it's very much in play
and look he's under consideration and
the fact that he is tells me it just
reinforces the idea of all this talk
about Joe Douglas potentially being the
guy with the Jets I I think Joe Douglas
is square in the conversation as at the
very least a favorite to become the next
general manager than your jets right
Douglas and dangle Jeremiah worked
together side by side in Baltimore
remain close friends to this day and
it's not hard to connect the dots that
if Joe Douglas winds up at the GM of the
New York Jets that he brings along your
draft analyst from Daniel Jeremiah as
his right-hand man and so that would
mean that in less than a calendar year
four or five six months apart mike
Mayock would go to the Raiders Daniel
Jeremiah will go to the Jax now look I
think that he and his family are pretty
happy in California there they're pretty
well-established the kids are in school
maybe his wife will be okay with it but
he's got a couple of primary high school
athletes out there when they're nearing
that stage but the thing that the Jets
can do is they could say we will tell
you X amount of dollars right and I
think that that's going to be more than
what NFL Network is game you know that
from experience I don't sound like a man
who's been knows that by experience that
sort of thing right there Jeremiah allow
me to say this deserves yes deserves a
big nice or he's gonna get I think he's
gonna wind up as a foreign office number
than irritates me it's great to be doing
with Jeremiah today that was about it
much leverage as could be given him as
it was when Michael Academy was like up
well and let me get to that Adam
Schefter here on the Rich Eisen show
why was mechag Ninh let go Adam I mean
what what can you what what where can
you pinpoint this to if you can bottom
line is I think him and Adam GaSe I did
not see eye to eye and they had their
issues and it went back to free agency
and disagreements of various players and
built up over time and I think everybody
had heard the speculation even on Friday
Adam GaSe was asked to address it and he
dismissed it and basically said he was
angry about the fact that he didn't even
come out or come up but obviously
there's something to it now I think most
people around the league rich all
thought that it was going to be
difficult for Mike mccoggins to hold on
to his job but I think that everybody is
surprised that that the axe fell on May
15 like that's strange and I don't have
an answer for you as to why I came down
today and not right after the draft or
right after the cease I really thought
going into this year I thought that Mike
would be given the season they would get
the chance to work together and then
after the season I thought that Adam
GaSe would move on to resolve the
general manager but today Christopher
Johnson went to mike McKagan and I think
surprised him and told them that we are
letting you go and we're letting go your
vice president of player personnel Bryan
Holaday right and I think I think those
guys I think they guys those guys
assembled what is now going to be a
competitive roster that's going to be
good for a long period of time I really
think the Jets are in a good position to
succeed they've got their quarterback in
the future they've got some foundational
pieces they've got some pretty good
players like they're a pretty good team
right now no I know that Adam my concern
if I just take that the jet hat and put
it on for a second is that of all the
conversations that have been bandied
about on Twitter today and from other
information sources that the the issue
that might have been the thorniest
between mechag ninh and gays from the
free agent front was the cost of fluffy
on bail and if there's any player in the
history of the NFL and certainly since
you and I have been covering it that
that has made it known how important it
is what he gets paid and has made it
known by withholding his services its
levy on bail I mean so is that true and
if that's true
is that gonna affect things with the guy
who's sticking around being the one
who's been rumored or reported to have
the problem with paying him as much as
Belle got paid I can't address the
specific discussions that were had
during a time of levy on bail but I can
say I do believe there's absolutely
something to the fact that the CAG
didn't engage had different views on how
much she's valued how much he's I don't
know the specifics but I do believe that
that was one of the players that there
were discussions about Shelley said hmm
now what can what went on during those I
don't know exactly you know I don't I
don't know whether mckagan wanted him
engaged in weather McKagan valued him at
a certain level and case didn't whether
case wanted to go for a different
running back again I don't know a lot of
people know and eventually over time
maybe they'll come out but I think that
there's definitely something to all the
smoke that has been blowing about where
levy on bail fits into all this mmm
that's not that that's no bueno Adam and
that's something that that lingers I
mean that's something that absolutely
unless unless cases first call as
interim general manager absolutely I
think it's an issue that will have to be
addressed you can't deny it right but
there are plenty of coaches plenty of
times who don't want a certain player in
the draft who aren't as high on a
certain guy in free agency worse no no
one comes in and they get along and you
know what I mean you know I say hey I
had interesting you this guy wanted this
guy want anymore but listen I'm fired up
you're here we're gonna have a great
year together when you go from there
right if it's levy on bail plays like
levy on bail I guarantee you him and
Adam GaSe really get along just fine
IIIi would think that is the truth but
we're talking about money it's not about
draft choice or positioning and I know
that that that's private or talking
about money alright so how does it
what's the time
this best you can tell do you think
Jetts Adam GaSe is now the interim GM
and I guess I'd be curious to know who
would succeed Daniel Jeremiah and NFL
Network because then he would be come to
the number one targeted general how
about let's put a pin in that
conversation and we'll revisit how about
that I don't want to give I didn't fuse
it with it's possible I don't know I
mean I could do that too but I mean you
know I'm just saying I'll just say I
want to move on I want to move on to
Cincinnati when it comes down to that
next question this next I don't know I
have no idea and I don't know if DJ
would want it or he would or I don't
want to speculate about a colleague like
that on the air but I will say this and
you know him he's a dog he's a dynamite
wonderful human being on the planet and
if that's what he wants to do and this
is the sort of thing that his family
would do then then bless him go do it
and and try and win it I mean you win a
championship for New York City with the
Jets I mean that is that's an old-timer
that's it that's a mic drop if you're
able to do that rich like I said like I
said I really mean this I'm like I mean
jokes aside Daniel Jeremiah is in a
great position because the NFL Network's
gonna step up and pay him a lot more
money or he's gonna wind up leaving I
think to go join the Jets death so good
for Daniel Jeremiah that's he's gonna
get paid his value and his work as it
should be nice
I'm all for that and so I don't know
what he and his family will decide I
don't know that ultimately the guy that
gets higher than GMA he's gonna know
wound up wanting him or not but it
really sounds like I'll say this it's
very much in the discussion which tells
you that you're Douglas is very much in
the discussion and so again we'll see
how that sorts itself out for danger
in terms of that time in the you asked
about look it's not like you've got to
go rush to go hire somebody you're past
the draft you're in the offseason
there's only one team with the general
manager of vacancy right now that's a
new objects so they can take their time
doing this but it's not something I
think that you'd want to have just
lingering out there I don't think you
want out of case going at the training
camp is the head coach and the interim
GM so I would tell you that they want to
get this cleaned up in the next few
weeks something to that effect right and
you want to go through and interview
people and talk to candidates and again
I think the league wide assumption is
that Joe Douglas is the presumed
favorite for the job and I think you'll
hear some other names come up like Adam
Peters and San Francisco but it's it
certainly sounds like it's Joe Douglas
his job to lose and we'll see what the
Jets decided to do with that over the
coming weeks Adam you're the man
Brockman before Adam goes just you're
the you're the impartial arbiter here
okay sure
Adam normally comes on the show and he's
very he's very passionate talking about
the facts he's just talks facts normally
right yes
did it sound to you that he had a
particular piece of Glee that there
might be somebody who can hold NFL
Network management over a barrel
did that sound to you did his voice
change that's joy I don't know am I
reading too much do you think sources
tell me that I saw into the situation
what do you think which I just saw the
cold like I see em I love you Adam
Schefter with every fiber of my being
sir thank you right back at you gotta
thanks for the time that's Adam Schefter
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on VR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app